first many of you tonight are very angry
rightfully so the fbi is blatantly
targeting our fellow americans for their
political beliefs the bureau's
reputation has been shattered my faith
in an organization i'll be honest i had
two family members they were deity my
family because they work for this
organization i revered this organization
for decades of my life if you listen to
my radio show watch this show you know
my love of law enforcement it has now
pretty much been utterly destroyed and
more specifically i just do not trust
nor i think should anybody be able to
trust high-ranking people that have now
perpetuated those people at the top of
the fbi the trump-russia conspiracy
theory hoax it was all a lie for years
they knew it was a lie they kept
perpetuating the lie those that
purposely lied to fisa court judges to
spy on a presidential candidate and a
president again and again and again and
they have hurt this institution we
needed institutionalized reforms we
didn't get that they protected the
corruption they protected the deep state
the raid on the former president's
private home is shocking it is wrong it
is a clear and gross abuse of power and
corruption the wall street journal and
their editorial board called it
dangerous and warned that a.g merrick
garland is now taking the u.s down a
perilous path he's they're right and
according to my sources tonight on
monday morning up to 40 fbi agents
rolled up to mar-a-lago unannounced guns
ablaze
in about a dozen vehicles including a
large moving truck over the course of
the next several hours the agents went
room by room scouring the property
boxing up every document they had in
sight they even rifled through melania's
wardrobe agents also demanded that the
mar-a-lago staff turn off all security
cameras well we can tell you tonight
those security cameras kept rolling they
were not shut off and now we can report
exclusively tonight that the fbi and the
bureau is desperately trying to obtain
all of the footage
i wonder why trump's attorney who was
there
that that morning will join us and tell
us what went on from their vantage point
and they were blocked from viewing the
the uh warrant at all they were forced
to stand outside the gates of mar-a-lago
while all of this was happening and
here's a shocker according to newsweek
the fbi utilized a quote confidential
informant inside of mar-a-lago who
assisted the agents with their search
and also tonight the media is feigning
indignation and outrage that some people
are saying that donald trump should be
concerned about the possibility of
planted evidence or bugs now let me be
very very clear
i'm not a conspiracy theorist do i have
any knowledge about any of this i do not
none whatsoever
but think of it this way had the fbi
upper echelon not lied to the people in
this country for years about donald
trump and russia and collusion that
never happened and had they not lied
repeatedly to fisa court judges so that
they could spy on carter page and
backdoor and spy on the trump campaign
transition team and presidency
i kind of tend to doubt anyone would
have any suspicion director ray should
have held all of those bad actors
accountable i said so at the time and i
was right or it would get worse he
failed to do so he should have cleaned
up the most prestigious at the time
of federal law enforcement agency in the
world he didn't do it and that causes
people to be suspicious directorate
could have restored the faith and trust
in the fbi and he has failed to do so
and meanwhile the judge magistrate who
signed off on this warrant was a big
obama donor with big ties to guess who
jeffrey epstein you can't make this up
who posted also about his hatred for
president trump on facebook he even
promoted this statement quote donald
trump doesn't have the moral stature to
kiss john lewis's feet
moral stature were getting lectured by a
judge that defended jeffrey epstein's
accomplishments you can't make this up
seriously and get this the judge
formally recused himself during a suit
between donald trump and hillary clinton
we have full details on that and much
more with john solomon tonight now by
the way why would the fbi go to a
low-level judge magistrate who was not
appointed by a president not confirmed
by the senate for such a high level case
and why would the fbi send 40 agents to
storm mar-a-lago for a national archives
request when they were already invited
in we'll give you more details on this
in a second trump's office had already
been working
to get these documents in the right
place in fact we have the document in
february the national archives they
released a statement it's even on their
website if you want to look at it noting
that the former president's cooperation
15 boxes were already transferred to the
archives months ago other boxes of
interest was stored in a room at
mar-a-lago secured with a specific
padlock installed at the request of
those federal officials following a
meeting in june they had been invited in
they got to see everything they they
asked the president to put a padlock on
it and they did and in august before any
kind of subpoena or formal request the
fbi goes ahead and conducts a full-on
raid guns a blazing that was months in
the making and we're supposed to believe
that this is totally normal that the fbi
is uh this is how they
they behave in every circumstance
this is the sad tragedy of this the fbi
that i revered growing up the two
relatives in my family
that i revered growing up that were part
of this agency they have now shattered
their reputation in all things
especially with donald trump now even
cnn's top security analysts said the
raid was dangerous it was not warranted
and it was only about documents for the
national archives if it was remember in
2017 former president obama you might
have forgotten this the new york post
remembered they shipped 30 million pages
of sensitive and possibly classified
materials to chicago and by the way he
has yet to return any of it to the
national archives not one page so is his
house about to get rated chris wray care
to answer and who could forget bill
clinton and and sandy burglar remember
the guy goes into the national archives
where it's already archived and steals
classified documents from the national
archives shoving him down his pants and
underwear and into his socks and his
house was never raided instead you know
he's everyone just said he was sloppy he
was sloppy find a few thousand dollars
slap on the wrist it's all over and of
course this hillary clinton who could
forget she stored classified material on
multiple uh private servers that were
hacked by foreign governments it put our
country's national security at risk no
raid on her home in chappaqua no charges
according to comey despite evidence of
law breaking his words not mine no
reasonable prosecutor would ever bring
charges against hillary right before an
election what about joe and hunter who
are now enjoying apparently a long
vacation
is the fbi is the raid of biden's
vacation home now imminent uh when will
hunter's phone and laptop be seized
christopher ray the fbi director has had
that laptop for nearly two years we know
that there's evidence of crimes on the
laptop we know that there's evidence
that joe biden was up to his eyeballs in
foreign business dealings with countries
like ukraine and russia and china and
one would have to ask the next logical
question is that why joe biden gave a
north stream to pipeline waiver to
vladimir putin is that why he wants to
remove tariffs in china is that why he
gave a million barrels of our strategic
petroleum reserves to china you know we
we don't now live in a country with
equal justice or application of our laws
that is sad that means we don't live in
a country that's living up to its
constitution if your last name is
clinton obama biden if your name's
hunter you can do anything you want and
get away with it but if you are a
republican if you support president
trump if you voice frustration with your
woke school board or god forbid run for
office as a conservative or republican
good luck because the fbi is watching
your every move and now this is sad but
it's true christopher wray appears to
care he couldn't care less all right let
me be clear and let there be no
ambiguity no member no member at all in
law enforcement should ever be
threatened with violence that can never
be tolerated now by the way i wish in
the summer of 2020 the democrats the
media and the fbi director would have
spoken out and defended cops like we did
on this program we had thousands of
police that were pelted with bricks and
rocks and frozen water bottles and
molotov cocktails they injured thousands
of cops over the summer of 2020 and yes
we do know that there are bad apples in
law enforcement but they are the small
minority including bad apples in the fbi
and then we have high ranking officials
that refuse to clean up this
organization the vast majority though of
law enforcement do risk their lives
daily to protect all of us and we should
honor them and protect them we defend
those who serve and protect we deplore
any call for violence and unfortunately
that's not true in the democratic party
don't believe me here's a quick reminder
so i know that there's an outrage right
now i guess about
protests that have been peaceful to date
and we certainly continue to encourage
that outside of judges homes and that's
the president's position
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you have released the whirlwind and you
will pay
get up in the face of some congress
people they're not going to stop before
election day in november and they're not
going to stop after election day and
that should be everyone should take note
of that on both levels that this isn't
they're not going to let up and they
should not
chris ray i know the department of
justice wants to look into parents that
speak out at school board meetings did
you ever speak out against those
high-ranking democrats who are
encouraging
writing encouraging violence uh the
writers to burn our cities to the ground
uh they're not gonna stop they won't
stop you better take note or tweeting
out a fund that gets the rioters out of
jail where were you in the summer of
2020 where were any of the democrats
where were you when chuck schumer was
threatening supreme court justices on
the steps of the supreme court where
were you when supreme court justices
were being doxed when their kids schools
were being doxed where the churches they
attend were being doxed or are you only
focused on donald trump and trump
supporters and parents at school board
meetings those mean old parents that
believe in age-appropriate material
being taught hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else